guarantee What's Up boo Parkin welcome
to the war Pope was a delivery for so
full podcast welcome to the were so full
podcast with Felipe Esparza and the
always co-host with the most from the
yeah man podcast
Rodrigo Torres yeah man how you guys do
it what's up flew right here at the
heart where it all began for the yeah
man podcast
how do your man parts are doing you've
got 26 episodes within one year SBCC
people every two weeks to see don't
worry about charting the more focus
started off at number 47 before I'm so
asking what happened what happened bro
how'd you get on there dawg you dip down
but if you were up yeah did I departed
for my husband on that new one I too saw
page that I know there's like yeah a new
algorithm that's what Aaron was coming
and then the got good number for the
first four weeks but it's cooled up I
mean people are asking me how I got on
there down you just gotta keep on
darling that you gotta keep going man
were so boom we just got back from our
Arlington Texas where the weather was a
hundred degrees 90 degrees with winds
and thunder storm I never understood the
type of weather man when it when it
could be humid as hell our sky like
super super hot but it's raining like
hell do thunderstorms and hail like hell
over there ha ha ha ha hell yeah crazy
don't be it nah weather Oh totally full
all my drivers still will notice
grabbing the weather to him I get from
Guam said yes unlike Vietnam
Oh a little fool words are titled
upcoming shows July first I will be in
Tucson Arizona at the Ewa amphitheater
with Paul Rodriguez and right after we
do a comedy show Paul Rodriguez and I
are opening up the show for check this
out Teairra
Malo and war yes I am Marlo and war also
coming soon I'll show near you I'm a bit
between a big show man
somewhere in Orange County somewhere
near the fog it's a big show I'll be
hosting was big bad Chicano Batman damn
and I don't know the other band that's
gonna be there but headlining law steals
at North 1/2 an Italian under sunny 0
that's right be people the dream has
come true
Felipe has crossed over to last thing in
the north the world the Tigers of the
north
look them up the American is Clinton
they live in San Jose now for mojitos in
San Jose we don't know the date yet so
it might get canceled but that's what we
it looks like right now
Chicago Batman no still the north day
Felipe Esparza and this is a guy named
Ali or some some guy named Callie
another artist alley man or kalila
Kaleo from Mexico tie july 13th to the
15th
course Briggs Christi Texas at mesquite
Street comedy club
that's right mesquite Street comedy club
in Corpus Christi this place is normally
a bar the serves delicious pizza okay so
go check them up July 2012 23rd that's
why cono I'm coming back to Tampa
Florida when the last time you were
there so like two years ago for Tampa
Florida turn a Spears at the Tampa
improv keyboard city huh Eber City Papa
July 27th through the 29th des Moines
Iowa Des Moines Iowa funny bones West
that's right there's two funny bones in
Des Moines but I'm doing the funny bone
West in Des Moines Iowa I'll get stirred
through the six Oxnard at every live
Oxnard these shows will sell out so I
will start getting those tickets now
because it's awkward and what do you do
on the summer Oxnard you go to the beach
and you go watch Felipe Esparza because
he shows up every summer
- take that what's up boo also
California shout out to Rick or Mambo we
have no bell sound eeny meeny miny
lyrically Mambo all right boo what's up
also that are all sold here man I'm
moving people that's right I'm moving to
the valley and we're having a fat boy
yard sale
fat boy yard sale we go into the valley
if you're a waste 4029 length pants
always 42 a waist 38 a waist
40 30 we catch you double legs
extra-large shirts
we'll be at a yard sale right outside my
apartment we're gonna have a yard sale
I'm a couple of suits for sale - couple
of big fat suits for so what's Heather
they wanted seven thirty eight thirty or
thirty forty eight code I think of 46
ship whatever we were the wedding by
will take over 52 L how about that food
that you want to know you don't want to
get a bigger jacket dog said it's not
gonna fit not what that would so or me
anybody man that once you come to our
Fat Boy yard sale coming up June 24th on
Saturday from 10:00 a.m. to 2:00 p.m.
and it will be in Glendale California
and we'll post the address the week
before the sale and we'll post about it
more on social media once we moved out
so get ready for that people big fat boy
yard sale for your big fat asses whereby
the captive on the cartoons it could
play a little show that living in line
with anyway also man Mark Snyder will be
calling in okay what's your shuffle 228
that levity loved it that's our producer
see right there by the way the new woody
oh my god look we got bros at us oh you
the [ __ ] entourage their entourage
now you got a published up all PR person
know anything about our lane getting it
up your person knows everything bro come
on bro good kill necklace you know very
buddy with what's a podcast I live over
the radio JLo the podcast work dog I
have people coming hearings want to do
your show what's a podcast
hey look it up it's a Wikipedia yeah man
sometimes go to radio stations and the
reading all my memo like all my my
information like words I worried it's
going word by word hey I heard I used
you were in a band bro back in the days
with mixed up questions and [ __ ] what I
do right now
they do their homework we're gonna get
to where bro so you're a show coming up
yeah yeah I'll be there on a June 28th
for the ones on one celebrity live and
then every Wednesday at Romano's in
Riverside about the people know where
levity like what city in Oxnard
California you'll be more specific
bro your [ __ ] answers are very vague
sometimes you got painted a picture bro
you know I mean literally live Oxnard
nobody know already we live as the
people don't know what a podcast is yeah
I'm the city dog you gotta tell me
address cuz it
you don't believe me bro you'll get
emails a what to the show starts other
chick is available could be my baby
they that's a solution every live we're
gonna be enough start brother call just
there how many people asked us we're
gonna be in Arlington after we left a
grip yet can't find it worse so we were
in Dallas Texas but we were we were in
Nam shout-out to that girl who showed up
to my show and with her baby member a
picture what's in her mind everybody yes
show that was her baby I don't know
where I really could bring a baby into
the comments left but anyways she
probably at her at her Monday crush man
Monday whatever and she had a picture
bein her baby I swear to god man I don't
know how how I know we took a photo
right but the photo it looked like we
shut that photo at her house DNA test
coming
pools our house a little my family like
I bet myself for the first time or G go
stay looking shiny this is the DNA test
Naxals do noses if you have a lot of
shirts you're gonna bring out that day
for that day yeah I'll have them out
there
I had them out there Ontario think
you're much whoever bottom no photo yard
sale
oh yeah did I'll have those shirts as
well just [ __ ] I've got a bunch of
shirts like dress shirt so that too so
should be the starting price for the
stores a yard sale well I'm probably
just 5 bucks right there's that too much
was that 5 you had a yard sale state
shake yeah we just had one deal with the
5150 no it was a family with muddy souls
in their way how'd it go
well you know they made it for money but
you know shot us up some some rims they
were gonna get [ __ ] you know but they
made all these 200 bucks
I say Magyar so had changed rolling I
tell you right now man people show up
with their phone and they look at the
price tag of a failure how much does an
Amazon and they see their worst nine
ninety dollars in Amazon and they see
how much the price is even if it's ten
dollars you know ten dollars the War II
will create a for five naked times are
tough
what's up fool what's crackin oh we got
a bad girl you're so two people well
they're fat boy yard so sad don't be
women's clothes I just found out squeeze
into them they'll be women's clothes
sighs Klaus will be size 8 and 10
women's size bed well honestly Air
Swimmer for me with my bros and we're
blanket up our lunches and calm also
there'll be kids toys their kids are
without broken toys [ __ ] yeah a bra
broken told you a blind kid is a toy
measurement motive elements a puzzle
it's a bird
all bad everything's bigger Texas man
everything except the seats at the Texas
Ranger
oh my god man we were so tired at scene
we were like a human jigsaw puzzle man I
was eating with one hand and Rodrigo
chicken on my napkin
the other hand I can't even get to my
napkin it was no diet it broke a pretty
connector and then I we were sitting
with Adam Murray hanging crazy a story's
this battered and abused kid oh yeah bro
that one opening book the I like battery
and abuse people they stay quietly keep
the little Sal day it goes a little
corner and right we're ready to work
there's a kid were you know man we still
have a widow anybody will have a sponsor
but we'll get to them later Pacific
company they have a dropped us bro
probably drop us I don't know hey uh yes
wrong boy yeah man you're popular every
week every two weeks
how do you find that doing the pocket
cuz I'm tell you do podcast talking to
yourself huh
yeah solo ones like I do the airport
ones when I have enough time and that
way to get loose for to get out and the
airport yeah so I pull out the little
recorder but I use my PK mic the PK
that's been on the what's up full
podcast gave us for Christmas and I
attach that to my iPhone and then i dial
it to a garage band and then do the
intro yeah but I bet I'm also starting a
we'll be selling a recorder for a pocket
anybody want to start your own podcast
Mantle's of the face they were sorry for
coming by already
mp3 recorder is the oil man did you do
it and I we sold out we saw one of the
one of those camera that I never got to
use GoPros GoPros
somebody bought it right away then he
had to throw the gray ones I don't know
it looked great in the being black the
greater yeah now that I said it back to
it for over no one I want to burn it off
is going on here I never let me go pro
because you can't even see what the [ __ ]
you doing bro just recording that dad
you can have a side forward man I don't
like anything we need a whole crew I
want to if I don't need a boom man you
know what with it what's up brother you
will give me a cocktail okay so doctor
it's a lighter because
I'm supposed to do in the hack man
anyway Banerjee follow George Lopez is
quitting comedy January fourth nineteen
2018-2019 man remember now don't open
who retire and and they'd hit a run for
mayor evangelist boss it'll be George
Lopez 2020 right now right now for mayor
analyst I know that's the idea for the
man I know that I know that's the idea
now la like four years ago you're gonna
do it well run from it a we saw in a row
for governor Phillipe it fires they're
gonna take it the empty seat and run for
consul men of Boyle Heights broke sorry
I just have start cleaning my [ __ ]
it's uh being sober they don't care
about that [ __ ] huh well did they catch
our one dude doing a railing [ __ ] I know
when Lopez runs when he runs then I find
all kind of bad photo bill stop
supported eyes
the first photo bunny pop out with him
passed out at Caesars in Canada that's
right you're laying right there
you didn't laying down now you could've
laid down for their City
there's always something back so I'm
gonna sue it though goes out mudslinger
come on with a sticker slogan it'll be
right now right now Blaine laid man
what's up what's up posted a mob ezel
hit me up bro our last guest I was here
what do we have our last guest is own
now Eric Griffin bro oh man something
that's a funny a comment about Eric
Griffin a man it's April that that knows
and that and that [ __ ] eyebrows no
glasses come together bro Groucho Marx
oh yeah did you get to watch the show
what show the one he's on poo
nah I'm not of course you didn't watch
him you will do the whole weekend show
time little tired of our [ __ ] we're at
the Rangers game dog [ __ ] them and then
we have to do shows he wants to do to
city whoever mine any Murray what's with
you on Sunday night nothing don't know
time to do nothing
it was [ __ ] hot really to get tender
puffs now we barely related
- back home hell yeah apples and then we
miss the storm for by light by ten
minutes already starting to drizzle down
well you go Nate this big big bucket of
tater tots man called up bases loaded
sorry it wasn't like I would like a dog
like a Dodger helmet full of potatoes
the people pretty risky that's right not
cheap I was a brisket it was alright bad
flavor
oh yeah but it was a little you know a
little dry it was a little first level
to ornament broke mando gonna eat beef
like that like raw beef brisket I feel
like there was a little burnt parts on
top a better football player yeah the
treasures don't [ __ ] around with help
and they had not - cheese and then bacon
and then sour cream and chives and they
say then man he barely been restful to
our live audience the hardest concern is
that yeah babies were loaded boy he was
full
you had to like take a little breather
dog then tighten it up yeah man you know
like people talk about there's no one
there's no bigger than Texas
there's no bunch of terrorists there's
no people eating healthy that's all true
man there are no fat [ __ ] are
sexes man we sell out of three eggs
they're all the time and those are the
women
anyways manager a week we've been but
there was a section you know that that
Dodger Stadium needs to add you know I'm
shot a Magic Johnson of you're out there
man the Carlisle Michael Duran make a
phone call
make jeans happen for us in fact we have
um they have a section that was all
mailing for a budget for vegans vegans
bro like and it had ballpark nachos that
were actually cheese that was yellow and
have vegan hot dogs vegan chili man
everything has a decent price I had a
vegan chili dog with [ __ ] nachos that
she was good and my stomach wasn't
pretty bad like his stomach man I don't
think a dumpster Haga
that's a service even begin food you
don't [ __ ] right away you don't [ __ ]
right away later on man
so let me ask you does it taste the same
it does take it it is a cheeseburger you
forget what it tastes like bro
but nothing is there wait for it for a
long time man you realized it by the
idiot for and I'm kind of curious and
mostly know that ops right best way to
beat diabetes it to be a vegetarian
vegan because if you start staying away
from stuff that's processed like just
like me for example I love sweets I love
cinnamon rolls like I cannot ever pull
over a taco truck I never had that taco
ought to buy it yeah but this is a I'm
vegan
why can't he meet a candy anything has
Lord in it I can't eat sugar I could
show her but a lot of stuff that I do
love has sugar like cinnamon rolls so
here is donors like if I really want a
donor I have to go with a Highland Park
to donor friend because they have big
and donors there but see I'm not gonna
make that long-ass trip so I'm gonna
take home and pure what I have at home
and it [ __ ] from the flakes let me
the real [ __ ] place I buy a photo
about a buy cereal and [ __ ] bags bro
right
there's no toy in there bro the only one
who the gift is you [ __ ] make another
report the gift is making the other food
for less with your life you're the best
dealer example I might [ __ ] remind
[ __ ] up my cereal look like people
look at me brother at it right here
right in that sack now [ __ ] possibly
I love it it tastes the same or even
better taste the same oh you know what
bro add more sugar you can offer it does
one cereal you cannot fake and that
frosted flakes when you get the real
faster place you know you know when you
got a boot cuz I switch boxes you know I
put the fake [ __ ] your place instead of
[ __ ] the plate box so my whole family
eating a fake properly and they ever say
shameful so I don't mind my stepsons
pertain to different life this was a
little weirder there's one cut my mouth
is been sitting there for days
let's call that every time I was higher
man so high I Captain Crunch without
milk man ma'am I [ __ ] at you cut the
[ __ ] on my gums go ahead that book is
sharp
you see really sharp bro you want to
kill somebody broke put a bunch of glue
on your hand and just grab a bunch of
positive breaks and laughs about April
Pelayo to be all scratched up [ __ ]
pretty for life were so cool
Podcast madman what today's episode no
not yet
today's episode is sponsored by our
friends at Dollar Shave Club
I'm afraid right here with a video Tory
has been trying it for like on a month
now oh yeah the Carver's a shape on the
works and it looks good bro I'll be a
little ass slap you know haha it looks
good you go further commercial real
commercial you put on the Aqua Velva you
you [ __ ] forget slap oh sorry yeah my
daddy to do it to me
Dollar Shave Club still going strong
sponsor inna the wonderful podcast like
a soldier because they know what's up
get your sketch your face smooth and
ready for summer by joining the Dollar
Shave Club it's the smartest choice get
highly quality blades and amazing dr.
Carver's shea butter delivered right to
your door for an incredible smooth shape
it makes your life easier so you don't
have to go to the store and get lost
looking for razors or [ __ ] look at
the [ __ ] manager Brooke you [ __ ]
open up the [ __ ] raid 0 you get the
[ __ ] key sorry bro
a little struggling with a key but I
can't open the razors I can't even open
the [ __ ] baby milk man everything's
locked up in this [ __ ] store bro this
[ __ ] place the [ __ ] Fort Knox
spiritual ghetto and sword bro
everything's locked up you never [ __ ]
stay we're locked up they got some
[ __ ] good wine locked up you got the
[ __ ] baby diapers like never got them
and well I got locked up
the cashier got a bulletproof I know man
there's a [ __ ] food on the phone for
the [ __ ] out my boy will make
personal calls it makes it just makes
life easier bro you don't have to go to
the store and get lost looking for
razors are cheap and flimsy or too
high-tech to understand man well also
women man anybody any women out there
I'm [ __ ] shaving their base JJ and
you're tired of using those cheap ass
[ __ ] your BIC razors are you know what
yellow one lets you [ __ ] touch your
crotch and people think you're on your
period
[ __ ] around the Razr ladies don't
play with you that raises no more man
[ __ ] what your mom told you man look
[ __ ] at that [ __ ] all hairy man who
wants a bush broke stay with no city I
hate that [ __ ] what tell me with a chick
man it was so hairy brought it look like
a coconut with a roller banner oh hey
now new hack it just makes life easy you
know do it for Father's Day shave it off
with Father's Day right around the
corner what better gift is there than a
membership to Dollar Shave Club a lot of
our listeners have tried it they posted
up they're all happy man a lot of you
pull that portrait up shaving
I'll keep our ugly fools bro get a nice
haircut and they post it up ready to
shine that's what happens done and women
like in our shower base to what people
are shower makes people feel good huh
specially man like you are dirty what
you owe sometimes you cook good we have
nothing no home to go to like a home or
you know you can share an apartment with
somebody
you come out of that shower man you put
[ __ ] baby powder on your feet you
feel good man how do you brush your
teeth like sometimes man that's how I
have some time I go back and we'll to
get to my room and [ __ ] you take a bath
bro and forget about everything and
watch forensic power they get paranoid
brothers coming outside looking for a
choice I'm all hi watching Forensic
Files and look at the hotel where
somebody got killed I think for Kate
those little jobs dated the Bates hotel
as one of our listeners for a limited
time only new members get there first
month of the executive radio with a tube
over there dr. Carver shea butter for
only $5 was free shipping after that
month the Rays are just a few bucks a
month
that's a $15 value for only five bucks
your first box will arrive and you'll
get an awesome heavy handle razor in
focus set of four cartridges and a tube
of their shea butter
no hidden fees no commitments cancel
anytime you want to get the deal joined
today a Dollar Shave Club cars last pool
that's dollarshaveclub.com /foo parlours
day get high quality blades amazing dr.
carbon shea butter well I didn't read
that I started out with that let's
martyrs choice get high quality blazing
amazing dr. Carver shea butter deliver
right to your door for an incredible
price then I went to the [ __ ] locked up
you heard the man yeah man we're gonna
call right now anyway we're expecting a
call from okay everybody supposed to
call but you know she's dancing the
whole [ __ ] mother storm Marcela argh
well you know our let our past guests
our home girl we'll be at the Arlington
giraffe house in DC Father's Day weekend
hell yeah so if you're if you're a solid
Orion with nothing to do take your
mother out to a nice comedy show or your
father you know maybe you don't have
maybe your mom wear the pants yeah you
never know the you know territorial
panel okay pelo mera Marcela Marcel are
we doing father's here that'll be a good
show because you know her father passed
away and she's in love with her father
every no couldn't be a very special show
man you don't know what's the buzz she's
gonna stay up there man so Father's Day
weekend check out Marcella argüello at
Don Arlington Trap House was Ringo and I
were there man and man which way what
happened man like a dumbass I thought I
lost my wallet we were looking for that
[ __ ] wallet
we could write we could've wrote a movie
about looking for that [ __ ] wallet
and Donnelly Linda Lee in your bag
I can't Lisa destroy the focus to do
their I felt bad because I really
thought you so I lost your wallet you're
all paranoid and crazy and I was like
and then this will go to the gym and
then you get to the gym I found my
wallet fool like I knew how to be in
somewhere but he flipped over the bag I
mean I didn't get a chance to look
through it but you know cash sold
everything but it was in a little nook a
little cranny right there
not wholly not a chance you know bad but
in this world upside down you can travel
are they to to another plane man with no
ID but man took a lot of time so the
next one hour for you next two hours and
she has to call it in Ketchikan some guy
and that person call another guy because
you know you can just call direct to the
government there's levels that made a
real Philippe as far as a please and of
that's what I'm here for
chaos so we all through different in
different planes this time where we go
flew in from Ontario Ontario and at
Amory Orlando he's cool huh he's cool it
was a three bro well I think he lunch is
over like a lot of topples have a little
scoliosis effect dog because everybody's
not that tall they've been down a bit oh
man I don't know I don't think like I
don't sure food I walk that down but I
watch your Tom [ __ ] that big kiss
that's a big back broadly with your
homeboy I feel like they're particularly
get out ago lethal ah the groovie
goolies doc all right Mandy
we got some more to cover man I put out
my um mrs. mrs. um Butterworth glasses
here born suspect Anthony citric couples
we have a whole bio for him bro you fit
here Richard I hope who wrote all this
all these guys are a little fertilizer
Julian Assange yeah man
I do I do wrote it from and then they
put it together okay I know but I might
have been changing pro before it was
like before my need to be like full of
tough streets of Los Angeles in
different colors you know like that
now that the Lord access to mill more
Latino actors who are not from
California they claim the hood now yeah
arm a from a laid are what I was gonna
realities County or put a mother ballot
or somebody to the part of Montebello
but then you start thinking okay the
good side you know but Walker your
region all right but you find out hell
nah they love deep outskirts of [ __ ]
um sounds Montebello Brotherhood ordered
by commerce that's all you know you to
the website because a little ball
apartment and a 7-eleven their Olympic
by leaders and they're back in if you're
gonna back up into your apartment you
live in the hood but I want to make a
fast getaway you tell me that man
anytime you see this on your level you
know your move yeah man excuse me pal
there's a hook without hood are there
was a [ __ ] 7-eleven in the airport
article oh yeah yeah Pizza two dozen
other videos of video games if you have
gas stations ever sorry liver yeah bad
man 7-eleven the only store that um when
they opened up in the hood they
interview homeless people men to see
which one could hang outside
sorry sir I can't do that [ __ ]
bandaged head bro yeah put a hat on it
but people get a [ __ ] broke on
the hood don't know [ __ ] about
gentrification or or don't know the
neighborhood's changing they get it done
having parades bro I'll call you to move
into a hood world I took that far take a
happy [ __ ] hood rats bro we headed if
we have zero hermano bail to hit the
coast get a black eye
Arco Junior with his lab to [ __ ] up
burning heavier load oh that's right
Bernie yeah bro to learn yeah do they
have the book pay yes
[ __ ] up my my daddy to love the salad
buffet and I was just over there one of
the first ones to start off with there
was a salad buffet oh yeah we have we
haven't we had none and the Lee McDonald
we had was the one on my lingo but at my
General Hospital the doctor in LA
then they made one of the projects an
intern Soto they finally made one um
she's our Chavez and Soto Street
tamarang goes like every stories huh
yeah man that police took my friend
brother they too bad I didn't Rolo broke
hardcore shoulder hits work was I eat
soup ugh we're gonna McDonald's dying
abroad are you to work for the Carnales
dog shut up dog
I work for [ __ ] [ __ ] always know
Ronald all my friends I have ever worked
to make done hooked me up with burgers
that's dumb hell yeah it's always a
hooker with somebody works absolute dog
whatever for your local all that is the
best when you can just go to a
drive-through or served our colorful
eeprom I got your order dog and they
make you as a double Big Mac a big mess
made out of [ __ ] quarter pounder B
song to my day would buy one thing and
just give you a bag full of [ __ ] oh yeah
a bag full of friends yeah quarter
pounder the quarter pounder cheeseburger
I'm afraid to hook it up and make it a
quarter pounder into a Big Mac bro with
Big Mac sauce and that is man I let my
tricks that's like a Robocop Big Mac
dude that's a tight man you want to
catch it
you want to catch gonorrhea man you got
throw your baby in that play play pants
look
what okay the most dirtiest [ __ ]
children [ __ ] we gonna play pit
people leave our children and go
shopping somewhere I am like McDonald's
restyling flu shots bro instead of
[ __ ] food bro so came out a cold sore
I know multiple serious [ __ ]
statement as well [ __ ] you look in a box
[ __ ] every fee-fi bro how do you fix
big bro like so your mom's tell you baby
their home take your shoes off air about
escape artist ranted about oh hey man
looky here the own do so all sold out
you're joining a growing numbers oh no
your mom way to show you a cloud you
know they should make sure I was clean
but I was one of those fools I always
have to take a shower I was like my
shirt gets [ __ ] up go get another one
here oh I know [ __ ] away if it gets it
how are you well your dirty ass kids
lose oh [ __ ] you I won't keep you so
yeah
but you take is over and he'll clean
though your mouth clean yeah really
really clean your house really
cleanliness [ __ ] done all the time you
probably like your mom rooting for you
like yeah right
I don't want the best for you yeah
exactly your mom rooting for you too man
you have to tell us at miles bro
because you're doing great and then a
toast edit or not like they want an
action happens they want to live their
dream through your ass like precious
emotional problems the kid - the one -
the one who looks for help I'm here like
that a useful I hate so scared cause I
hate to dad like just because he's
sucked in baseball I got a sub to tell
all those models man like like just like
you say dumb
your daughter goes to summer camp and
she start meeting like like at this
episode of Moore's a new black totally a
hood rat mom right there man so the
episode
always a new black the little smart
chick the little Puerto Rican girl
what's her name Dana XD - thank you -
character she was all smart she liked
painting she liked arts but her whole
family were [ __ ] Cholas bro everybody
with a drug I it was a drug dealer bro
they were ready to art
raising so she goes to summer camp at
all and she loved it she didn't want to
go and they loved her bro they want to
give her a scholarship and then the
monster happened she was with other
women who are not told us she goes you
like go in there you want to hang out
with us
so instead I get a story on senator
summer capital more because she was
jealous brother have started with having
a good time with other girls and older
wearing her side holding her back so now
she [ __ ] know me so you gonna go and
meet me how we were shopping
we're gonna go [ __ ] hey go my friends
and get our nails done a [ __ ]
screw your dreams yes but so much
something like [ __ ] me and bro like
that bro he got me home he was [ __ ]
dumb he never see won't work with him
bro like that's gonna go work with you
yeah on his on the stuff he had did that
take you to work that was a real role
play they say yeah I took my salsa words
but that would work on sorry bro
I know what time it was
dark thunder bro like that was still
under the hood fish in the car
everolimus Alberta rain like a soldier
looking for last team or something even
asked me to help car had to get takes
time happy to help but my door like hey
Leo grow like 31 good my dad like Hank
Hill bro he don't want Bobby around hold
the Crescent wanna [ __ ] dumb I'm his
only [ __ ] wide out kind of that but
you fell you cry one time that's enough
for him to not take you to [ __ ] help
a pizza truck
what is the rarest positive here is here
that ring is here man his bio bro it
make some jokes
haha citric Campos do you know your
cousin Rico Rico and Rico couples or
they deliver the project there was a
little compost yeah
the only Campos we knew beside his
address daughter I did have some sort
cousin illicitly so village really the
offer pingos glass like the backside air
by the 5 freeway that's what I'm talking
about my gosh a compost
I don't know this no no they said
there's a duro tall dark this is a guy
named rich man's been around a bro who
Richard Campos he's a cop now he's a
sheriff real cool guy
then his brother Marco Campos he's like
some douchebag that were said [ __ ]
another mission huh and then there and
then but they all graduated from USP
even even the ones that were going off
the side dad they all ended up going to
graduate him an but the dad brought
hardcore darker solo that food hardcore
so that foo got shot up
Brody my little drive-by he was like in
his fifties but it did a drive-by and he
was so drunk and falling the other
bullies mister prefer the original
matrix like he was like falling for like
the other bullet shot miss him he got
shot in the arm Brody flexing a bullet
damn
but everybody was like was wondering how
the [ __ ] just putting a shot and killed
yeah yes you see what happens when
you're not hollow glass but you know her
x-ray that we survived
because I'm drunk bro when you're drunk
you're so scared of you don't even know
what you going ah ah
but everybody else is holding their
muscles in broken did that hold on
August 6th sense riser you were their
common dog samurai you know that we were
driving yesterday we saw a car that was
totally [ __ ] wreck man at least chick
was going where the [ __ ] has I did I
don't know what happened she had nothing
in her car ran into her she cut out that
guy and that guy again was driving too
fast and made a turn [ __ ] AK so just
broke and [ __ ] Hey look we're talking
about [ __ ] freeways here dog okay
let's get the traffic born and raised in
Boyle Heights as a child
the trick was impressed but with
performers such as Michael Jackson and
John Travolta and dream of becoming a
performer one day cha-cha votes are
really done sanic fever I said all right
I'll get grease oh yeah summer lovin him
were put on hold with as a teenager he
became actively involved in a gang after
years of living on the edge and on the
wrong side of the law citrate decided in
its early 20 that it was time to grow up
and take care of business with his son
when his son Eric was born so your
grandfather bro yeah got another one I'm
wearing a damn - two grandkids wild man
young ass grandfather your grandfather
bro thank you thank you anyway I would
never get fat
what is that all that what happened to
you man along the way man because it's
funny man when I'm little kids like ours
like us we want to be superheroes or
it's funny men when them and growing up
now when you you get older and you feel
you start to figure out the world
somehow like we were kids they will take
her to field trips to places where you
eat like they like making you go to that
career like okay what's the police
station who the [ __ ] goes to approach
them to a police station
ghetto kids do I don't you know why kids
in a white neighborhood making a [ __ ]
field trip to the police station you
know meet I went to the police station
to kill a bunch of times bro and then
there was an adult okay going back when
a man so that we go I always ask what
that door was now I'm in it
fireman bro yeah they do go to do a
fireman it took us to talk I remember
the fireman to a big three climb the
pole we never went to a computer in
computer school listen to Google they
make this we're a little kid when we
wanna meet we're too stupid for you to
understand computers at that time I know
that my kids today man computer lab with
one computer okay now he's kids to there
but you're born with a [ __ ] iPhone in
the [ __ ] tablet tablet and [ __ ] a
laptop since I'm getting man I remember
tell us that I'm the world's that you're
at your hand push it now the world that
you had literally you would be a movie
you wanna [ __ ] make a movie you could
do with your phone you wanna write a
script do it on your phone you wanna do
a [ __ ] porn do it with your phone all
the really you couldn't do it when I was
a kid will do a point you gotta find a
camera
those mattress mattress that is a
willingness an extra a fluffer
write a screenplay
all that [ __ ] cops party someone's gonna
hold the boom when you were a kid man
that you want to be like a performer
yeah you know I just saw I want I don't
know if I want me to do music or acting
I just wanted to be in the entertainment
business and so I started gaining to
breakdancing or during the 80s I was
like a big [ __ ] your firebrick that in
crew uh yeah we're watching it your
gangs ahead yeah what is a [ __ ] okay we
has well also one of the football teams
that turned into a game oh yeah I got
the 5150 Ching gonna be opening up more
solid car bucks yeah let's talk about
that how did how will 5150 started and
who the hell runs in there's so many
people are popping up talking about
Oh Lord CFL got a guitar solo to a show
in our New Mexico bra neither one he's
the owner is affiliated with you I
forgive your [ __ ] arm like I'm
traveling bro I am [ __ ] traveling bro
I am I'm a dark-skinned Mexican along
here why would you give me a Mexican ski
mask
they can travel with we give me a
[ __ ] hockey mask bro so Jason is from
Jalisco he gave me a hockey map bro what
are we gonna poke a hole up the airport
over here Lee yeah to clarify everything
basically the partners in 5150 Brandon
is George Robert Stephanie and myself
Robert is a Filipino guy right now he's
Mexican
please this will appeal okay okay
another guy put a little they look like
color he was glasses he has like the
owner I am thank me on everything bro
goes to the supermarket like that not an
intern or something yeah I don't either
gotta taste one for the team I think he
was a guy he was I think that guy that
guy he was a guy before over 5150 before
everything when they were all just
regular can tha hood they will try out
the drug hi everybody
hey bro here so tried a new PCP okay I
[ __ ] order that's a bad bachelor get
5150 bro really sort of brand because I
don't roll around Reuters is you right
yeah looters but you know it's also a
part of branch off of um of a 5150 but
loot is more like for the street stuff
you know it but we working on a couple
other ones like a little bit more in the
mainstream but Louisiana is part of that
in
5150 I mean we have a lot of people that
are associated with the brand in the
sense that they're buying gear and
sounding it at their venues or whatever
you know so we give them the wholesale
price and they go out and they do their
team awesome yeah that cut up the middle
man right there and the mini man how
long hands in around for well originally
robbers the one that started the whole
brand he
in Oxnard as a recording studio it was
called 5150 recordings and now used to
get all kinds of artists from back you
Mitchell DJ Quik VJ yellow from NWA you
know I like all these big artists
Takamori record we should take a trip up
to Oxnard and then I'm he started doing
guy misses you know that said I'm 5150
recordings and then people started you
know like started he did a couple
different logos and he landed the one he
has right now
people started is pretty dope man like
let me get a shirt and we get a search
so the teachers of business started
taking off from more than then dance
studio
so we kind of closed the student for a
while and then he just started getting
into the t-shirt game and that's already
been like maybe I want to say like a
good with five years be well did five
six years and pull even more actually
5150 means crazy right yeah I probably
like 10 years I want to say oh that well
that's the police cool but but we
switched it to a positive know where
it's like be 5150 crazy about chasing
your dreams whatever it might be whether
it being entertainment doctor lawyer
whatever you want to be but you know be
crazy enough to change regime because
you know not everybody good
I don't know mess my doctor showed up
with a 5150 had to operate out the other
day I don't know about this doctor man
it's a little uh a lot man I saw my New
Mexico giving us shirts know he's doing
heart surgery
yeah well yo in some of the stuff like
it's for big-ass fools are like yeah
like it's like well I ever seen one guy
where a large bro I don't think this
everybody has either long horse or
support a no well we wanna pop rocky the
brandy ones are going on ml and I love
you know the little box you know the
little guys but they focus on the I'm
the big box 202 3 X 4 X weigh 140 bro
look if emu malaika's you know was it
was Lewis over so big guys that we're
hearing is only a member so with the big
sense so they're not worried that it
that works
yeah so we don't want to discriminate
but it's very [ __ ] mayhem you know
for the four or five minutes for the big
guys you'll build like a bull because
your bro like like just big in a show to
our show bro we need to start making
vibrate and when the world ends our
everybody can look at it right yeah
anymore
limitary on the [ __ ] I think that
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is speedy
[ __ ] prize bro sorry but yes in
my bag you'd be putting forth you can
see normally 45 for Excel and p90 dogs
there's something people got understand
I guess pricier the bigger the shirt the
more the more the shirts I know that we
got all that better suit the blue fools
active they don't add extra cotton to
that shirt yeah it can't give me the
holding price rope clicking dog and
we're going to stay in business we gotta
get rid of the homey price alright stop
asking for the homey price start asking
for the hook-up time ask you when Jordan
Lopez gonna be there so I could be there
how about as soon as I show what were
their gears when you're selling your
gear but iconically alright does that
well can we [ __ ] it
can you wear my structure shirt the
brand kind of like yours a roaster you
give me your lady's number broker took
example can you go to the holy
brightness
I'm pretty sure if you get that to me
and you think you saw my shirts right
here real quick he was gonna focus with
your source under mine sorry bro there's
no food for we're depending on side with
a tote bag
haha everywhere that's a bootleggers get
not yeah well that's an anything bro no
I can already imagine you know it's like
I mean there's probably somebody out
there somewhere doing it but we just
haven't seen it but you know I mean it
just comes with the territory you ready
no today world man yeah yeah yeah you
know it was Tito is crazy that um Eddie
Van Halen owns though he owns the rights
to the actual word 5150 oh because you
know they had an album the valley now
was back in the days it was called 5150
and that's his am so yeah so that's
that's his whole thing so he owns the
rights to that and when he seen George
wearing it one day he looked at George's
a man I wish I woulda came over to have
fun because he like he really liked it
ah she's dope so you know so so we got
it we got the blessed from that dude
that's awesome bro hell yeah
so LZ okay come on yeah man fifty nah my
podcast right is you guys he goes in
three years ago by one I'll get you one
yeah make one so I'll go a little bit
too accustomed or don't even when I
watched I meant when I was king of the
hill now since you were you were against
that time or what king of the hill I
would surely guess is that Danny Trejo
or is that sister talking could you
guess on the same month uh and uh I'm
the [ __ ] under car to me because you
had a funny ass joke about a home at
scheels it was that Danny Trejo is more
of a wolf voice in you cuz I can tell
the distinction on there about that good
evening sounds like you know not that
you know you don't sound like you mean
business but you know distinct thing
like hear that old and I mean hold Ondo
listen I think you look more like a guy
calling in to UM to our LeBeau ha ha ha
ha ha very distinct a solid guys calling
into promoting stuff like you're more
likely back he's more like in a hurry
I'm more like a Lobo dog but Danny Trejo
in a million years he would have never
thought that there'll be a [ __ ]
doughnut shop named after him no no I
should tell you folks I like the fat bug
yes beauty was now dude the taco the
rear side of the taco no no no I mean on
an open everybody media yeah everybody
says install the first day of Dona they
sold out yeah [ __ ] I bet 51 Pitre coffee
lots bro 5150 coffee house bro wire
everybody overlapping but I thought
you'd care she got me off pretty Bowser
got me making 20 why ya know dog like
like me like me I want to like throw one
soft food everywhere man I put it
everywhere bro [ __ ] barbecue sauce
focus it's a lot of waters my wife
thinks I'm crazy
you know cuz I wanted like I were to
make like those you know those digits
table
I want to put my water food logo on it
and sell it for $10 up to the show and
she was talking about you what I did to
the pigeon the pigeon see the business
let the fridges peel it business I
mentioned what's up poohbear
you gotta yeah you got a brand new [ __ ]
everywhere but then again man I don't
wanna [ __ ] people hitting me up a
month later they put a [ __ ] barbarian
my lady my fault dog I know you [ __ ] you
so much a pig dogs Oh putting focus with
a pigeon Sweeney opinion to see sense
[Laughter]
this empire crumbled inspired by Latino
hip-hop artist Jeff rock and mellow
Bernie citric started performing with a
hip-hop group round town looters in the
1990s one other singles became a huge
hit in Japan citrus and the group had
the privilege of traveling to Japan to
headline the annual Japan lowrider Super
Show all that they said Japan a writer
so much oh you go to Japan already super
sure why are you like that again they
learned that Penal Code trail of rose
lilo matter here in America they love
our food not us
not exactly what came first the taco or
one tinder for one I think one because
they all have together make the talk
around for geo Google broke it down so
many went to Mexico City it said there's
no bull Rita's over there yeah door
knocks one of the real there's a spot
where you go and that's all they focus
on but they don't they don't really 1111
they make like tacos latina it is a big
taco yeah what they call in text
vehicles here a [ __ ] over there coming
up with you - not like tacos anywhere
but Mexico City in this place in
California that's it well the extra
grease on the forgiveth we'll make sure
with them a little bit of it you know
gonna lose a little little little dip
and it was nap I would have I think
that's a secret to the [ __ ] taco
my brother or the king of order burrito
and running with a B oh God
I'm gonna say earlier like we're in high
school you can do speedo order something
Donald's they give you the bag take up
to the driver
brother brother knew that does that
chocolate chill was laughs on the inside
with a vertical rather but the inside he
knew the never chase him bro so just be
holy like his money like this he's gonna
give it to them and they'll go to
burrito and jam bro Jam Jam and you can
do it screw failure or ten beats as I
speak for burrito brood of horrible kind
doctor okay Terry and then war burrito
job now I didn't belong to a head on
talking goosebumps all the time but you
can't get away with that [ __ ] no more
man they [ __ ] hold the bag before you
pay ah
I mean if the state PD gotta make it and
that's on you yeah you're a Vietnam you
but if you can get away with it bucket
you are and you are listening to Anthony
says it's doubtful I'm mad at you not
cool hoodie at hell hoodie Thank You
Carter you coined a term that's a real
trick question
they hold about tight odd now they're
better now man they papers oh yeah they
charge you for a second before ready
just chip the truck over bro before you
just grab a sword or bad while you're
talking to the taco lean out no more buy
more ears you've got this wonderful to
get sighs yeah yeah they got everything
locked up it'll trust us
yeah now you know it's just [ __ ] you
know couple fools just [ __ ] up
[ __ ] ghetto our fool would be worried
okay see what pretty sure that's all
they remember they don't remember your
face would he remember the series don't
we need memory subway to blow up 5150
pros and somebody go out there man I get
in a car chase on where bro right you
were 50 all over your car imagine it'll
he was wearing a 51 painting shirt
that's all it takes doctor
gotta go viral plan okay exactly ready
it's going to go by to Motoko every time
I tell you go viral they happen bro just
gonna biros I don't know that pain had a
virus on it
imagine bleed you gag
my laptop remember the old-school way we
need when they would hack your page and
in a bunch of windows capable ah where's
your ears after they were freezes at the
power look like a computer a hooker no
whack at porn side to player so we
should you know I just learned over the
year not to pick on stupid [ __ ] like
yeah ugly or anything that lies to me
like telling me hey handsome
yeah I'm new in town cuz there was a
little testing me you want to come chat
with me
hell no the Rangers out I well AOL
that's how you know to drop a manager
but we have an al-qaeda see anybody of
the AOL account come back me I don't
believe him huh hello 99
Wow get out you a yahoo messenger exist
anymore this [ __ ] talking about getting
me a Juno and oh so Japan is gay for
Latin hip-hop ah yeah you know we went
out there and we [ __ ] uh
we had lined up we had land the Super
Show we were like like tripping on I
went before without words is there as
openers and then we were asking the are
trippin that I was with the you know our
guide human and which also was like kind
of the road manager he would you start
asking to me like err who was performing
the shader and then at 30 kids I would
mean it yes I mean who's that lining
that full of those I we were [ __ ]
stupid you know and they said he just
said you guys know you know they'll have
to solve it but yeah you still going
wrong room see we only came and prepare
for like maybe three maybe four songs
got some covers and then after down so
we lucky my DJ at the time DC clear has
all our instrumentals he just said he
goes just in case anything [ __ ] pops
into it was I'm taking everything so but
he didn't tell me he just you know leave
that he was just prepared so please egg
I got the [ __ ] whole album we're here
we have him I got the Hallman will do a
whole [ __ ] hour right now we're so
yeah we're not doing the whole hour dude
and I almost fainted don't we nor was
born
oh I was done at the end of that set man
I couldn't [ __ ] talk for like two
days without up
because I wasn't really evil he shows it
like like an hour long that's a weird
one at ten minutes 15 minutes of that if
that week Santa it was so windy he
couldn't say man we should ask for more
money
no I was already aware charge if I want
to know we could ask for more money
that's as well cheetah behavior but
that's right that's when you're winning
show business and you have when you have
a woman as opposed to a man is always
better a broker may wanna hang out is it
via homie take you out you know others
there you know it's all about it's all
about them you know a lot that corporate
they nobody bullies them dinner
somewhere are you gonna cut make that
[ __ ] phone call broke me off I'll
make a phone call right now you just let
that number I don't have a number
right on point glad you're always gonna
be hard ad bro it's two minutes how many
times she called a bunch of times bro
such a dimension right you wait about
who working with the [ __ ] speed
everything that annoys me but she was on
it you know she was on it I'm not hating
on the red she was using her [ __ ]
jobs go to John right she's other well
shut up to Veronica Veronica shoutout I
think we met before you were in charge
of the kid from star maps no welcome boy
I saw some boy
alright and [ __ ] better your Python
I'm done man she knows I'm gonna say
that men are wack but you know men are
good once they're on top already at the
manager of the Asia but starting off nah
man am i lazy bill they want to be the
stars like it would it be Puff Daddy bro
yeah right it was fun with Mike like a
friend she got a lot of guys that want
to help out and promote this but they
want to be like this he got mad me and
says chick
we started off together create emotions
um open up a store and you Mexico the
lies
Oh George Lopez's house everybody sold
Moses right here for a burger one
country's leaders day what's up
yeah this is a long season uh what's a
fool [ __ ] yeah hell yeah we put on all
men in the business but how many times
you try to hook about a comedian for
anything just [ __ ] wack but I'll bet
they do they don't promote none huh oh
yeah man we had a we had a we had a
wheeler get the rapper right here a
Latino rapper and his manager and all
those people they got they couldn't find
your dress they couldn't find the rental
car we're late on the rental car they
were late on on address oh man we could
make it there it'll be an hour late for
I'll let you do it some other time bro
yeah no respect to you man but no
respect too catchy but you know the
candidates all hit the hit a hit song
I'm a little jealous dog there's no air
you got it you gotta have the right
people around you man [ __ ] missionary
you know man smooth you lay it's like
you love your friends but sometimes
that's where they are bro just friends
you know they're never gonna make
they're not gonna go to it they're gonna
go they're gonna be with you and always
be you can always be my friend bro
no matter what you're gonna be my friend
but we're never gonna be business
associates
I'm not gonna come we're gonna give your
jock line oh you're wack I ran out the
hard way I have no driver license dogs -
a [ __ ] how good is it to the gig if
we both gonna get a car look it there
anyway there's a will there's a way
right this goes back to a guy I met you
know a lot of time ago and I push you
your uh your press release your
publicist gonna press releases stop
[ __ ] my face it's a news conference a
publicist does the president any way you
publish this to know like how many times
you run into people like this how many
times she read Marisol right into it you
lisa us hey bro bro you you bro
I could make flyers bro I could make
banners bro I could um I could promote
your dog you know
as I like I got a bunch of phone numbers
and all right bro you got a card or
something nah brother the card I'll
write down for you yeah no we were in it
we've heard that we've heard them
[ __ ] ah we get them aloud everyone
gets this for your stuff that there's no
guests it brought me showing up to any
van with doors a couple of handshake
dogs there's no meeting greet dogs Oh
cuz I wouldn't bring my mom man she
really wants to meet you and they lie
who do they want to be hold my baby
there's a green room attic we're busy
wants to meet you it's a swell party
Boyle - your publicist from from well
whatever would consider other by Lena by
my hasn't yet but has the projects I
know where that is on her solo bro my
first-ever library book was from the
Wabash library and I remember there
should I under the giant modular giant I
was cause it was check-in a bean stop
know that's big book and everything I
was so sad I never once heard it she's
my mom my parents were it did an idiot
will do know that I've work school it is
a library one time and I never went back
to bring the book back
how much you wanna say trying well I'm
like Al Bundy right now
sighs Cobra toiling in butter you know
what but the public library any but the
public library is there for only one
reason bro for guys like us can pull off
pull over and drive and take a good [ __ ]
dog right if you can do some cold water
on a summer day hell yeah man so good
nothing today relief like taking a nice
scooter or library can I see those yes
grace you don't work that home but if
you're in a big city library play the
gentleman at a big city library like Los
Angeles to New York City you know or any
big library to not and I repeat this do
not take a [ __ ] in the regular men's
restroom there that's a homeless guy
shower you go in there's a homeless guy
showering well you take a little walk to
the kids section
the kids bathroom it's cleaner and you
say what happened with your son here no
managed somewhere around here it
happened to us in cocaine remember that
one homeless dude that would to the
restroom and blew it up
oh really people oh my I didn't go in
there I'm not found that [ __ ] but blew
it a sport but we were running lady
walked out with her eyes watering out
gagging little Asian lady was mother -
oh god oh girl there's also get into
fight with two other schools that's a
bad mouth enough a nice [ __ ] someone
also he's a check at the public library
to Spokane library bro it was stuffed up
if you want a floor and nobody wanna
clean it all so everybody was going
inside and then walking back out they
look furn - a bad No - you would endure
PE brownie here so it's [ __ ]
SOP brothers brutal dollar sad bro you
know it smelled like man grow up in that
mother you were took a dump a good jump
and use toilet paper and then wash your
hands ten times and your hands - it's my
leg with a [ __ ] like you don't have a
[ __ ] on your hands bro it's so [ __ ]
about 20 people to be lingering enough
it's two days later bro you still smell
it but it's a little big Donnell food
now you can't get a Big Mac 10 hour from
now but you still smell like a happy
meal after has had two of them dog
rewards are so bitter
yeah man a clean leaving she began
hosting a hip hop interview show on
local TV station and booked his first
acting job as a background performer on
the music video little girl a boy with
dr. Dre and Snoop Dogg he was the cholo
to the left behind the other solo yeah
actually we look at the video you can
see but it wasn't the ball headed
troubles at the time we had a little bit
of hair fade like a little fade
now I was all buzzy with just one the
number one hello Libra and when I had a
number one oh come on Indo guys
look at my window guys a little
something right yeah yeah it comes out
when you see the video that's what my
head looks like a running around in the
jail scene then you were harsh times
yeah
the Christian burial and Eva Longoria
hang out with them on we had a war we
hung out like I wrote on when a
Christian everybody was in April booster
yeah I think he was I don't know what I
want trained it'll be on 10 faves I
never saw he owned the company he's been
he's been fulfilled but I but I remember
was training day or her style machine
we're making we were Nicky Nam
we're shooting the Lopez show Lopez
other show he put me on now the comedy
get me I'm gonna get down there how many
get down bro
and then we were shooting a scene
another sterling that guy oh gee goon
stir and the other four were talking
about with the glasses I looked like he
was could be 150 and Robert so gnarly
very contagious and it showed up and
[ __ ] Nate Diaz from there are we're
pretty well pretty shun the guard yeah
bro I'm gonna get job here I don't know
where bro in the Octagon I don't know
I'm wrong just it's not get to us soon
really became part of the scene okay
yeah man you got me whatever they deals
was throwing yeah last minute yeah he
was like like last minute but they get a
full script right away so I just picked
it up and never act in his life exposing
me when you never acted on your life
normal words that you'd normally say in
real life
for the first time or hard to say good
Italian to say it not neat are you gonna
do a Taliban now man we just hanging out
over there hey cut did again look what
you just do your way dog Hodges on bro I
feels harder I mean he said I mean I
don't really I don't know I can't
consider myself
full-blown actor cuz I've only have
maybe like blow a role you know I'm just
an actor anywhere do what I do but I'm
not real
I really like this you're a working
actor bro I'm working with any CD but I
mean I did a I just look at it like [ __ ]
I just do what I do with it
even I Masada started to my homeboy
humble homeboy meek now but you gotta
get a resume protected like some people
think oh [ __ ] I see not book i've seen
every episo-- i see double zipper
Marshallese
to the [ __ ] deleted scenes dawg I
watched IMDB you did not come on em and
try to cause as much as you can put all
I don't know take this I reject the
credit for the caterer and a driver yeah
they say they give you rock if
everybody's credited no [ __ ] well that's
the thing about that you can't lie can't
lie on the resume you gotta be straight
up straight forward how about the
independent movies work everybody that
acted in the movie didn't get paid but
they're also executive producers also
here every time you get hit up a bro
we're gonna what kind of get this
fundraiser going man if you can just
show up every George I get quite a few
minutes like in quite a few money sort
of tell you it's crazy man and you know
everybody expects doors to show up like
man you know that guy's [ __ ] working
when I stood up at that store brought
into my store is crazy man oh man
citric you're not show with more MORE
yeah Rodriguez this was moment on
anarchy bro here with us move on sons of
anarchy with that [ __ ] I'm I saw
you in it - yeah was basically I mean
it's not like it's not a spoof it's just
like it's kind of just comedy just about
these guys that became a
a biker gang by action in the shots on
[ __ ] prospect in the foot long story
so they had to become a biker gang and
I'm the I'm the I'm the the president of
the other bike baby I'm the real biker
gang mighty soul plays my wife and then
CC from K days she said I mama said that
she plays my mistress which is homegirls
with her so it's just like ability but
but these guys these guys are all
comedians [ __ ] turned into bikers by
accident in the suit so it but it's
hilarious when George George saw the
original trailer they did George said it
was hilarious and he got the script for
the first episode and he [ __ ] he goes
a man is something yeah I want to get
behind so he was so he signed on as an
executive producer so right now we're
not sure exactly what's it going to be
if it's gonna be on television or web
series but it's gonna be a series for a
long history series so now it's gonna
probably I'm thinking between uh I think
maybe 30 minutes at you know roughly
twenty to twenty something mid twenty
two minutes and then uh and then uh
twelve episodes I believe that's what
are you shooting for so we'll see then
he's on funding away run into a flower
amazing expensiveness you all think it
is o minute it has already start
production air well the the things we
aren't even started production we just
started doing promos and the problems
just to build the hype and then so now
the hype is key can't be kind of get it
out there so now you got all these
different investors and network that
come to the reads we have a table every
Thursday so they come through and they
sit down and they check it out so we're
just trying to see what's up what's the
best option you know and and of course
George he's doing his thing on it on
this part you know so so we'll see well
we'll see what it turns into man with
you guys posted I know they want to
write you guys in that's it
Esther she's choking which wonderful a
little heavy choking whatever that ago
know y'all are forgotten to be fans out
to greeny yeah you gotta do anyone in
that wooden society with guys also
survivor here I gotta say that he just
took a lot of [ __ ] about George Bush you
know how about a Rasta if you don't have
that Arase he never helps of that last
out and look at ha ha
to have to be inward you know a change
that to have a record dog nah bro
the truth would you don't help out bad
script paper you can say that look
that's what it is
no but people say like you know help a
lot last night and remember man when
George Lopez brought me up on stage like
a locust you know I was so excited just
to be on the show I didn't even know
what he said
this was not on TV my lip was got hard
right now cuz you know I got ignited
we're not when a legend gives the
acknowledgement in oil Oh to cry when
you said I like to be did I don't like I
don't like a lot of I don't like a lot
of Latino comedians but I like this guy
I was about giving Phillip Esparza or
Pullip Esparza with the hat who's
smarter
you know like word so no gripe nothing
you know every time he will show up to
the Ice House I would just say what's up
George shake his hand and get the [ __ ]
out of the way you know and then I Paul
Rodriguez to shake his hand I'll give my
dream shake it get the [ __ ] out of his
way Leslie inviting me over to sit down
then I talk now that's a big [ __ ] you to
other comedians they were at their Sons
of Anarchy show afterwards tons of
Anarchy the one they were talking shared
that show local cutting his burrito
maker
and they're gonna kicked our comedians
bro any the first time their children
and kicked our comedian I was there the
first time it happened I was already
outside so I didn't feel like I get
kicked out well Joe dope is trying on
new material and he kicked out a bunch
of losers the right and copy jokes and
say I bro that's how I got to be too bro
that happened to me too bro bro happen
to you too but you know what happy to
George first and he said it first is
that why it becomes George joke that's
all [ __ ] words you know hi I got about
building a car right after solitaire
means put a [ __ ] Fiesta board about
38 years of show biz yeah man told Billy
tell you know pain Jews people don't get
it was so Jojo pencil not even know what
happened but he told me about it this
comedian was talking [ __ ]
you know but people are kind of Rocky's
brother youngsters learn what the [ __ ]
but Kato drop has a burrito machine it's
a [ __ ] you George Foreman grill there
you go
and the thing with George Wright is real
talk that if he if he really likes you
he's you're not easier now he's gonna
work with you it doesn't matter what
race you are who you are in on and if
you see you grinding and you know doing
your thing that that's [ __ ] that he
admires and so you know who you grinding
that dog I was it older grinding on the
pole I mean I think up high like him
ploy on a movie
what's that Johanna do I still want to
show everybody so let's color deported I
am look at the LBA when Philippe and
Paul Rodriguez and that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
hilarious hero till really the shark was
brother and Exeter way was that theme
directed and produced by hair and
standing and he was he was a historian
so a nappy a son it doesn't it and his
father in the dollar when you got you
welcome a crazy plasma seminar Philippe
in I and I thought this was [ __ ]
hilarious and when he's at Palmer they
had a little kid over for their [ __ ]
for their shots
it was [ __ ] comedy stop hammer toe
cheese and when you think of George
Lopez I linked up with him a couple
years ago with um the writers from
Silicon Valley and then the writers for
for Lopez that John all sugar and they
make risky they the the hit me other go
away we we got this up pilot on a shoot
and it's what George Lopez you know are
you interested something what the [ __ ]
am I gonna say bro course I'm interested
is a bike in Iran I read forever you
know when I wait on a reefer we went
over there we had a meaning then we sat
down with George in the the writers and
and and some of the other cast that with
that we use for the pilot we chopped it
up we read and then I was a first time I
met George Rose was just sizing me up
now you know it was early in the morning
like 75 mm I'm George bro you know takes
off his glasses
he's the size here then shakes my hand
real slow and boom and then we read and
then he said you know what the way you
read right here he goes you were going
into the next room with all the TV line
executives go that's how you better read
over there and I like far so he put the
press
I mean and we got on when he got to our
first line I was stumbling but I
copyrighted winning after that I just
read it all smoothly and you know tv9
[ __ ] loved it
did I mark my rounds of Bank addition to
now he was also there with uh he was
I've met him that same day - he was
brought in by also by John but John also
her and I we met that same day and we
like we're just ripping out you know you
know and I was tripping out on a gazebo
you would use [ __ ] wood comedy with
his rants and I go dad he's doing he's
[ __ ] this isn't acne or this is
really him but that was really him
so you [ __ ] cool homey - hell yeah
right I tell ya I did cut into a silicon
valley and I saw the episode of Days Inn
I'm not just a day like educated ass but
it was Farley dog it was funny it's
funny when you know the guy and he did
it because you were like a one knee
Twitter graffiti art and I forgot of
slow dog I've heard go away I'm in the
wrong neighborhood now you in a room you
know that he played a tiger that was
very popular in the hood you know like
like he was charging his foods like a
walking $100,000 for a paper of graffiti
painting right yeah together yeah um I
think at the end I forgot my right word
bro yeah the inner binder I think it was
like a million data bind up supposed to
paint a painting that he supposedly did
they bought over like a million bugs
yeah that's what I want street artist
David Cho yeah little thing for a
facebook and got in when he cashed in
his shares to 240 and that was and that
was one of the lines in there in that
episode that we did I played that the
character chewy and I was one of the
night and I was telling them fools I go
I wanted a deal like Dane Cho so he said
I go and says that was like I want the
[ __ ] you talking about I'll real done
again I'll you know what that is with
that shot in a values it is effective
Ally now you shot that and actually okay
the house is shot and Encino but the
part way around on the street we're out
there in Long Beach in the were
somebody's neighborhood we we almost got
hit up to but some real some real
[ __ ] contain alive bolongo da
here
have a repro clean [ __ ] around over
there nan dog streets don't fool ya man
yeah don't you
so what you got coming up next just you
want to show working under the terms of
anarchy and at the same time we're we're
we're trying to shoot uh what we're
trying to shoot like it like a teaser
sizzle reel whether you want to call it
with the show that that showcases like
me and Marisol our home life but it's so
catching the whole brand 5150 all the
[ __ ] we go through all behind the scenes
of everything you know and maybe some
behind the scenes if we can you know
like being on Lopez and one where
Georgia shows where we have the booth
set up all the drama that goes on over
there to that we have Dylan's you know
so which I'm a showcase all that so
hopefully uh we get somebody to pick it
up you know we got our my PR people with
super super sonic media working helping
us with that so hopefully yeah hopefully
we have the recommend to watch money so
are you with a daughter on TV right
we're gonna have a two year we're gonna
soak these actresses it's comedy I'm
still if you hang you hanging over there
all day it's [ __ ] comedy man roll her
page in comedy haters for the most I'm
too heavy
yeah your lady has [ __ ] hater for
[ __ ] kindergarten bro they keep
following Iraq you know you go all the
way from head starting that's a real
this time other news we go ahead god
please okay no zebra people want to know
what's going on in people's lives again
I want it all suppose I follow people
bro who I don't even know why not
following me you know find out what's
going on hey rod man is what your
brother's dead [ __ ] I said it he desert
I saw you guys I thought the way to get
home no Hawaii years ago oh we're man
but I would say when you walk up to
these people and you know everything a
bottom they look you like you're a crazy
person right I'm so sorry about your
brother passing away you know two years
ago I know member I have you picked that
same and some same
[Laughter]
Hey oh [ __ ] higher later total genome
and I will talk with you later
yeah if I can they come over no [ __ ] you
know they can't let it go so TV lab
can't let it go let it go lingering dogs
tons of an agree that's coming up on a
web series that's what we're we're kind
of shooting for right now but if we
could get it on network then that would
be good to you what kind of what the
Sons of Anarchy teaser on YouTube yeah
it's good or Instagram or on YouTube
just but I think right now on this
program if you go under tons of an arc
EMC then you see all the other problems
that we've been shooting
shut up to Mom or Rodriguez yeah I don't
know I knew that would restart do a
comedy man and he'd been riding since he
started and he's to write on the little
homies show the little homie yeah I'm
not so great I mean I be raining it's
liked him yeah I did it boys it was an
alley TV right Holly really yeah my mama
Rodriguez is only getting worked on on
the homie show writing and didn't get
paid at all they finally they were
talking about you know why broken he
have a woman published in wrong right he
did have a fever behind of asking it's
nothing out here woman it'll be [ __ ]
stupid brother for free anyway so it's
[ __ ]
you can he poke your role like a lot of
[ __ ] and I written ahead a shout-out to
really bad head up he got the credit
yeah and a GoFundMe page later too huh
I'm gonna do most pay home with that but
your car Maryville thanks Erica so
column I see Ernie just have birthdays
where's our peers our karla macias
cousin us cabin real hunter in was of
food and we're looking for publicist CR
he landed hard media hahaha shout out a
cholo looking for active word will
connect you to a meal or a better
shuttle to blend Carlin in Ireland yeah
men right
always like when I see